non tu veux essayer
mon dieu est témoin allez on essaie on
ne fait pas pipi dans les sacs à main on
entend partout d'où un certain monsieur
faisait panne c'est la dernière chose
que son père lui a offert alors y est
très attaché il veut attirer l'attention
c'est évident voici notre fille rebecca
as tu vas leur répété mot pour mot ce
que je dirai aux jolies superbe
pirouettes et je voudrais te voir toi
ton père a acheté ce chat dans ma
boutique
est-ce que tu le savais mais on s'en
fiche contente doit traduire je me
souviens qu'il a dit qu'il voulait
offrir exactement ce que tu lui avait
demandé l vieux chamane jetez pas fait
venir pour que du vignoble et madame
vous pourriez nous laisser seuls vous et
le chant oui d'accord